the winner and the original song
category is the best original singer I
know he's always true to the lyric and
the melody which today would get him
drummed out of the music business he's
responsible for the survival of more
evergreens in the Forestry Service
as a dancer he has nanou Pierre needless
to say he's the one the only the
original Fred Astaire
thank you so much um the nominees for
outstanding original song this year are
candle in the water music and lyrics by
al kasha and Joel Hirshhorn nobody does
it better
music by Marvin Hamlisch lyrics by
Carole Bayer Sager the slipper and the
rose walls he danced with me she dust
with me music and lyrics by Richard M
Sherman and Robert B Sherman someone's
waiting for you music by Sammy fain
lyrics by Carol Carol Connors and Anne
Robbins you light up my life music and
lyrics by Joseph Brooks and the winner
is come on Fred Tipton you light up my
life
oh boy thank God it's over
it's been a long kind of hope I am so
happy that after all this time it's
finally here thank you all very much I
really appreciate
you